hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
klassiker nämlich die käse sahne torte
ich persönlich kenne niemanden der die
nicht mag und wenn besuch da heißt dann
mache ich die mal ganz gerne weiß genau
weißt die kommt immer gut an und das
meiner meinung nach leckerste rezept und
wir fangen jetzt zuallererst an ein
bisschen boden zu backen und der geht
auch super easy und für den benötigen
wir ein warmes wasser mehl zucker
vanillezucker und etwas backpulver und
für den teig dem wird entweder die
küchenmaschine oder das handwerk egal
was ihr da habt ein zum beiden jetzt
gebe ich zuallererst die eier in die
schüsse gibt da das wasser mit doch zum
fahrzeug wundert warum verwende ich
wasser das lässt die einfach bisschen
besser dick schaumig aufschlagen das
hilft so ein bisschen
hier kommen noch zucker und
vanillezucker dazu und dann auf höchster
stufe ungefähr fünf minuten lang
schlagen
[Musik]
so nach fünf minuten ist die masse
richtig schön dick cremig genauso
brauchen wir die auch und jetzt machen
wir weiter mit den trockenen zutaten und
jetzt nimmt ihr euch euer sie und gibt
mehl und backpulver rein
[Musik]
soll als nächstes nimmt ihr euch euren
teig schaber und rührt die trockenen
zutaten gut und dann ist der teig schon
fertig
[Musik]
und das war's schon heute der tag schon
sehr viel ich sonst mache ich ja immer
so dass ich die eier trennen und und
brauchen wir bei der torte nicht also
genau und jetzt gebe ich den tag hier in
meinen ba kram den habe ich auf 26 cent
genau auf 26 zentimeter eingestellte
könnte aber auch eine springform nehmen
nur so zur info hamza gramm und backing
das mit synonyme das ist das gleiche
prinzip eigentlich aber wie
für den teig habe ich jetzt auch mal ein
bisschen glatt gestrichen und jetzt
kommt ein im vorgeheizten backofen bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze 22 bis 24
minuten einfach die stäbchen probe
machen und dann schauen ob der tyczka
ist doch bis gleich seine boden ist
ausgekühlt und damit er nicht
austrocknet könnt ihr feuchtes
küchenpapier obendrüber legen aber wir
machen jetzt die creme dann zeige ich
euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten
wir benötigen mandarin aus der dose den
saft habe ich auf gefangenen brauchen
wir außerdem zucker kalte schlagsahne
magerquark hier habe ich mit 40 prozent
fettanteil adina sahne fest und wann in
der extrakt oder vanille zucker so wir
kümmern uns vorab einmal kurz um die
saarner die beatles in der
küchenmaschine auf höchster stufe schön
steif geschlagen ihr könnt natürlich
auch ein handrührgerät verwenden da
gibt's jetzt auch noch seine fans dazu
damit es schon fest bleibt
[Musik]
nach wenigen minuten ist die sahne steif
und ich gebe es jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
denn wir machen jetzt auf dem herd
weiter und wir machen jetzt weiter am
herd wegen der agah tine und bei käse
sahnetorten kann man auch seine fest
benutzen und bequem fest zu klingen aber
ich finde das muss immer somit ganz
feste konsistenz haben
da ist bei mir wie suzanne todd noch mal
so ein bisschen speziell deswegen
benutze ich hier engagiere und ich habe
als flüssigkeit kein wasser genommen das
wäre mir zu langweilig ich habe einfach
den saft aus der mandarin lose genommen
200 milliliter einfach abgemessen und
die gibt ihr zusammen mit der agad ihn
in den topf
[Musik]
und damit die akademie ist studieren
kann muss sie erstmals zwei minuten lang
spielen kochen da macht ihr am besten
den stoff voran und nach zwei minuten
sehen wir uns mal wieder so die zwei
minuten sind um die arbeit nicht sofort
weiter und anders als bei der gelatine
brauchen wir bei der agad ine kein
temperaturausgleich was jetzt unseren
ertrag angeht deshalb werde ich den
credits direkt einmischen
[Musik]
und falls ihr es fragt ob ihr kompletten
magerquark nehmen könnt die ganzen 750
gramm das könnt ihr auch tun
ich tausche nur gerne ein drittel davon
durch den 40-prozentigen auswahl das
noch ein bisschen cremiger schmeckt und
jetzt gehen wir noch zucker und vanille
extrakt hinzu und danach kommt die sahne
wieder dazu
so die zutaten sind jetzt im topf alle
miteinander verrührt und die müssten
jetzt eigentlich auch schon abgekühlt
sein das heißt jetzt kann die sahne
hinzu wenn ihr merkt dass das ganze noch
ein bisschen lauwarm ist dann gibt die
sonne noch nicht dazu dann kühlt das zur
sicherheit noch ein bisschen mein
schneebesen kommt jetzt aber weg machen
wir mit dem teig schaber weiter und
jetzt wird die sahne ganz normal
untergehoben sowie ihr das auch von
anderen cremes kennt
[Musik]
und ich merke dass mein topf zu klein
ist zwinge mich gleich im inhalt teenie
schiffe also nicht wundern
ich habe ein gutes augenmaß aber was
töpfer angeben was katastrophe ja so die
creme ist fertig und nicht wundern dies
noch sehr flüssig die wird erst über
nacht also nach der kür zeit richtig
schön fest so wir können uns jetzt aber
um den boden der ist ja wie gesagt schon
ausgekühlt das ist auch ganz wichtig und
ich mach das jetzt so dass ich das oben
etwas abflachen werde mit meiner torten
säge dass es auch ein schön geraden
abschluss hat und dann wird es einmal in
der mitte halbiert
[Musik]
nehmt ihr euch eine tortenplatte eurer
wahl
und da gibt jetzt erstmal den boden
drauf ich mache das jetzt so dass ich
den oberen boden jetzt darüber gebe
damit ich den richtigen boden als dekker
bis klingt verwirrend ist aber total
logisch dann habt ihr nämlich einen
schönen geraden abschluss so und darüber
gebe ich jetzt einen tortenring
so die kuchen reste nicht wegwerfen uns
nicht ganz lösen mit euch ihr müsst zu
essen zum kaffee oder zum kakao zb wir
machen jetzt weiter ich gebe jetzt die
hälfte der creme einmal auf den boden
und dann kommen die mandarin ins spiel
[Musik]
für die mandarin minute in der torte
versteckt und jetzt kommen die restliche
creme oben drüber und dann schön glatt
streichen
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch der deckel unserer
torte ich habe ich ja meinen tortenboden
und einen torten einteiler
wir müssen den deckel quasi also die
stücke vorher schon ein schneiden weil
die creme sehr weiches und wenn ihr das
nicht machen würde dann würdet ihr die
creme runterdrücken beim schneiden
deshalb teile ich das jetzt ein
ich nehme jetzt 14 stücke und dann
steige ich das schon mal vor
so die stücke sind eingeteilt und jetzt
gibt dir die einfach nur noch auf die
torte und dann könnte das so ganz leicht
andrücken
[Musik]
sobald wir dann den boden an der
oberfläche so ein bisschen zurecht
gerückt hat und gerade gerückt habt geht
ihr einfach dem torten retter wieder
oben drauf oder einen teller oder
frischhaltefolie je nachdem was sie da
habt und dann kommt das ganze in den
kühlschrank für mindestens 4 stunden
damit die agah team auch schon fest
werden kann oder noch besser über nacht
[Musik]
ihr lieben ich hoffe dass euch das
rezept genau so gut gefällt wie mir
meine augen die allerbeste käse sahne
torte dieser welt und falsch ist ganz
jetzt machen möchte schaut auf jeden
fall um die info-box maschinen die
genauen mengenangaben ich freue mich
natürlich wenn in diesem video fleißig
eindeutig nach oben gibt fleißig
kommentiert schreibt mir noch gern was
sie als nächstes sehen möchte dass
nämlich immer gerne in meiner liste auf
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr auch
meinen kanal abonniert dann verpasst er
auch nicht mehr
und haben sie die die glocke aktivieren
genau wird sich das du nicht an aber
dann bekommt die er mit wenn wir neues
video klein und ich freue mich wenn wir
beim nächsten mal dabei auf die gis
kitchen tschüss